this is film courage you can find our
show a Sundays 12 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time here on la talk radio calm as well
as on movie garage film courage calm
iTunes and pod bean today we welcome you
to a special Wednesday edition of film
courage my name is karen worden and we
are glad that you are with us this
afternoon we are super excited about
today's show here the special edition of
film courage my name is David Brannon
our guest host today joining us in
studio is herself a radio host a writer
writing coach and founder of right on
online.com Deborah a curling right on
online is an established community for
writers throughout the world also be
sure to catch Deborah's radio program
entitled right on online meetings which
are on blog talk radio the second
Wednesday of the month at 12 p.m.
Pacific on blog talk comm slash right on
online it's been over a year in the
making and we're just super excited to
welcome you here to the studio whatever
well thank you so much I'm so happy to
be here and it's it's exciting for me
too and what happened with my live
writers group is we got so big and
through Facebook and Twitter I had to
move my meetings from Santa Monica to
BlogTalkRadio okay and it's in that
lovely and and I used to do them on the
evenings and I recently moved them to
noon pacific and it's just fabulous
we've had some great guests and it's
just it's a great way to as I do bring
community to writers throughout the
world so which is something you all do
as well we're very very in sync with
that yes we are so thank you so much for
absolutely writing me to join you thank
you it's our pleasure
all right well our guest today is a
woman who has inspired and changed
millions of individuals lives creatively
Julia Cameron joins us via phone today
on this very special edition of film
courage award-winning writer Julia
Cameron is the author of 30 books
consisting of fiction and nonfiction
including the artist
way the vein of gold and the right to
write her best-selling works on the
creative process in addition Julia is a
novelist playwright song writer and poet
and has distinctive credits in theatre
film and television thank you so much
for joining us today on film courage
Julia hello
well you're very welcome good to be here
it's wonderful to have you yeah yeah
this is super exciting for us Thank You
Julia for joining us here let's go to
the beginning as we do on film courage
we're curious where were you raised and
what was unique about your childhood I
grew up in Libertyville Illinois which
was a little town about 40 miles north
of Chicago's I grew up in the woods you
know yellow house we had many small
nooks and crannies and my family was
great readers so you would lion on the
hall on top of the heater reading your
novel and my mother would take us to the
library once a week and we were allowed
to take a 14 book which gives you some
idea of how much is how fast we will
read well you know we were neighbors I
quote well not neighbors I grew up in
Highland Park Illinois so there must be
something in the the water in the lake
back there yeah began the catering
company be so wonderful so can you take
us back to where you were in your life
when you began writing the masterpiece
the artists way I I wrote it
thinking I was going to unblock like
people who were very good friends who
were blocked
and I wrote it sort of aiming in
particular at a man named Eric Brian
whom I subsequently married but he had
come to me and said would you read a
hundred pages of my writing and tell me
if I'm a writer and I read his pages and
I thought how can he not know he's a
writer and so I invited him to come to
my living room to the little clusters
that I had formed of people who wanted
to get unblocked instead of being
grateful said where's the book I said I
am the book he said it should be a book
it could help a lot of people so what I
started doing was writing an essay a
week aimed at him I would think what is
what does that jerk need to listen to
together this week he's so stubborn he's
so arrogant and I so I wrote the essays
at mark and they built up and they
became a book interesting if that's it
it's a great way to communicate because
I get a lot of my writers where do I get
started what do I do and I love that
that you wrote it to a person and that's
the chap I think blocked people can
really use yeah no I'm just you know
milking this for all the extra info I
can share yeah the book the artists way
has been used in a very similar way as
the 12 steps of recovery have been used
did you ever envision that this would
spread I know you you wrote initially or
you you form this for those six people
that were blocked but I mean your book
the artists way has had such a wide
reaching and everlasting result on the
recovery community as well as for
artists did you ever envision that this
would be the case I know that you're
quite intuitive and I just wondered was
this something that you saw before how
I have to say I cheated a little bit
here I have a good girlfriend whom you
may know of a writer and a psychic then
Sonia showcats
mother yes and I went to see Sonya and
she said the artists way is going to
change your life and the life of anyone
who touches it's going to be a very big
book so I was sort of warned and then it
it grew in little dribs and drabs for
the first 100,000 books there was no
advertisement for them for the book it
was strictly word-of-mouth and I still
think word-of-mouth is the dominant way
that they are dissuade stress and Julie
you are known the world over for the
morning pages as I wonder what what is
the origin of the morning pages well the
morning pages came to me I guess what I
called sort of marching orders and
marching orders are very strong
intuitive guidance and I was living in
Taos New Mexico and I was a Hollywood
screenwriter at the time and I had just
had another one of my movies bought and
not made so I was really feeling sorry
for myself and my guidance when I was
out walking told me to try writing three
pages every morning so I would get up in
the morning and I would go to my
typewriter which looked at a task
mountain and I would write three pages
and I think I had the same feelings that
people do when they try it you know they
say boy
I I never realized I was blocked until I
started doing morning pages and then I
found myself facing down a lot of demons
and what happened to me was I was
writing the pages in writing in longhand
and then I suddenly had a character come
strolling into my room and I had
accidentally unblocked myself as a
nihilist instead of a screen writer and
I went back to New York
taking my novel with me and when I was
in New York I was walking in the village
you know it's beautiful beautiful light
cobblestone street and I was cursing God
I would think either get my movies made
or stop giving me movie ideas too
painful to have been bought or not made
and what happened was I heard teach and
I was horrified and I went home and I
called up a girl friend of mine named
Regina and I said Regina I've been
praying for what to do next and I got
told to teach isn't that awful and she
said well just a minute I'll call you
back so she called me back two minutes
later said congratulations you are now
on the faculty of the new like feminist
art institute in your first class moods
Thursday Wow
talk about all the stars aligning at the
same time that's just amazing you know
Julia how do you think stuff like that
happens you know when that when the
universe aligns the stars like that work
what is the source of that
at all times and I think when you become
willing to hear what it's trying to
teach then we experience synchronicity
in the experience of synchronicity you
know is a very powerful and startling
one and a lot of times when people start
to work with the artists way and they do
their morning pages and do their other
states they find themselves suddenly
being in the right place at the right
time an awful lot and then they realize
oh my god I'm putting things out and the
universe is responding to me I know
another thing that you talked about in
the right - right I believe was that you
know being so tapped in as you are being
an intuitive being that you've had ideas
come to you only to find out that they
were actual real life people that
somehow it just kind of came to you from
the ether or whatever term you want to
use but that you you were actually
tapping into real people and they were
manifesting on the page can you talk
about that a little bit I want to say
that I I wrote thrillers as a
screenwriter and I began to be
frightened that if I was putting so much
darkness on the page I was inviting it
into my life I was asked to write a
television movie on the hillside
strangler whom you might remember it was
a Los Angeles serial killer and when
they asked me to write the movie they
were convinced that I could do a very
good job doing it and I was convinced
that it was a terrible idea to invite
that man into my home so I turned the
job down and Julia when did you begin
writing the morning pages and have you
ever stopped writing more has ever been
a point your life since where you have
not done
morning pages I think we should pause
briefly and explain that morning pages
are three pages of longhand morning
writing that you do first thing and I
started writing them in about 1982 maybe
I have written them faithfully ever
since and it's interesting mark my
ex-husband he and I had a conversation
not too long ago where I said to him do
you'd still do morning pages and he said
I do morning pages whenever I get in
trouble and I said Oh sweetheart you
think you did them all the time you
might not get in trouble and that was
probably the reason we got divorced a
lot of the writers that I know and I'm I
love what you just said that was just
wonderful they they're always coming up
with excuses this is more important
that's more important what do you say to
people who think that their other thing
I mean other than you know you wouldn't
be in trouble if you did them but what
do you say to people who are constantly
making excuses and not I learned that I
don't deal with those people very much I
really think of the artist way as a
program of attraction rather than
promotion and so I don't ever try and
tell people uh so the the people need to
be the people who are getting with the
program are getting with the programs
what you're saying right okay I think
morning pages are contagious if I teach
a large workshop over a 12 week period
which I like to do I should add by the
way
I dreaded teaching and then it turned
out to be the most wonderful location
and it keeps me unblocked you know you
can't teach creative unblocking without
staying unblocked yourself and I'm sure
that's why I have 30 books because I've
been so much teaching what you just said
a moment ago Julie you know it makes me
wonder in terms of the people that you
have around you are are you really
protective of the people you have around
you and sort of the energy of other
people your route you allow into your
well I
I have something they call believing
mirrors and believing mirrors are people
who use their back to use your potential
and your power and I'm careful that my
early work goes out only to believing
mirrors and my believing there's an
example Tony show cat psychic Laura
Letty who is a gifted kindergarten
teacher dried hacker who teaches grammar
school English in New York
Tim Farrington who said he's my favorite
writer I should put a plug in for him he
wrote a wonderful book called the monk
downstairs and then followed it up with
another wonderful book the monk upstairs
and I've read his book like six times
over impotence started me writing my own
novel Mozart's ghost him had such good
humor and too enticing did not try to
write so again I guess what I'm saying
is that creativity is contagious
you kind of don't need to worry about
vlogging people into doing it
if you if your own life starts to change
it puts out a power of attraction you
know I have another thought about the
morning pages you know I got to come
back to this you know and in these 30
years that you've been doing morning
pages and other people have have come
across this and they've begun on their
path of writing morning pages says
anyone ever honestly come to you that
that is performed these morning pages on
a consistent daily basis and and told
you you know what Julia these morning
pages simply don't work they're waste of
my time I was teaching in New York New
York open sender and so it was a 12-week
course and we were about nine weeks into
the course and a girl raised your hand
and she said Julia nothing's happening
for me nothing is changing for me
nothing is working for me I've been
doing morning pages in other states
faithfully another thing has changed and
I said well I find that difficult to
believe but I think if you signed in
nothing is changing you should quit the
classroom and she said but Julia I'm
getting so much out of it now Julia I
believe you mentioned previously in some
of your writing that when you first
presented the artist way to I believe it
was like a high power agent but maybe
back in the 90s they said to you to some
degree like you know who will want to
buy this book so you went ahead yeah and
try to self publish until someone found
it to be the gem that it is but what
kept you going during that time
especially in the 90s self publishing I
don't think was as popular as it is
today what gave you that wherewithal to
keep going well I I come from a large
family and with my family if you learn
to tie your shoes you taught your sister
how to tie her shoe and I think I had
that same impulse to share with people
who needed it and we
self-published the artists way before
into culture and we would Xerox again a
little communist bookstore and bind it
up even we sold it through word-of-mouth
and we sold about a thousand copies
before it went on to Karcher so it's
that family conditioning that kind of
never quit and that should with you and
you took it with your work as well well
you know I would get a letter dear Julia
I am with the State Department in
Switzerland I hear you have a manuscript
and of course I would think I always
knew the State Department is paying too
much attention
well you're known of course for the
morning pages you know getting that sort
of mental minutiae on paper and also the
wonderful artists dates also though
something that's that I'm finding out is
that you're a big believer in walking
and I know you you've quoted Brenda
Yulin I believe and and other people on
it and and I know for me I have to have
a walk every day it it gives me
intuitive dreams and it helps with
stress so can you talk about walking and
how that kind of that I don't know if
it's part of the spiritual radio kit
that you talk about but how it's such an
important component to keeping sane I
think and when you do morning pages you
are attending you're sort of saying to
the universe this is what I like that's
what I don't like this is what I want
more of this is what I want less of and
then when you go on your artist page you
switch the dial over to receive and you
start to have hunches and intuitions and
many times people will report back that
they saw the conscious contact with the
benevolence something when they did
their art estate and then
when I wrote the artist way I I was in
week 12 twist all the way at the end of
the book when I said PS exercise is
important and I did an essay on exercise
now in the years since writing the
artists way I have realized that
exercise is pivotal and that what
happens when you walk is that you
integrate the inside thought that you
get from your morning pages in your
artist state and you begin to experience
the world as a benevolent plate
particularly if you live in a city like
New York which is I I lived there for 10
years reasonably and it's a big
overwhelming city and it's frightening
and then you start walking and it
becomes a city of interlinked
neighborhoods and it becomes much less
frightening and much more exciting I'm a
firm believer in in the power of
exercising and it sounds to me the way
you think of it it's the writing is the
excerpt and this is the way I think of
it too is the writing is the exercise
and the going out there and being with
people is exercise and that they're all
joined together do you have another sort
of exercise in addition to walking that
you enjoy doing that you find fuels your
spirit well I'm I'm pretty much of a
fanatic Walker and I haven't found it
necessary to go to any other forms but I
know that swimming works beautifully for
people I've also gone through periods
where I bicycle and bicycling work so
it's any regular repetitive
I yeah I I do martial arts I do Aikido
and I find that that it's I have my
Sunday class and when I have to miss it
I really I find myself doing it at home
just so I can get my balance on and
prepare for the week so routine very
important as well we are currently in
studio with guest host Deborah ackerly
of right on online and we feel
privileged to be on the phone with world
renowned writer Julia Cameron I found a
quote online and hopefully it's accurate
it says a perfectionism is not a quest
for the best
it's a pursuit of the worst in ourselves
the part that tells us that nothing we
do will ever be good enough that we
should try again and I believe it's from
brainy quote calm I believe that's one
of you right that good accurate quote oh
good okay you know what I've observed
from very successful people is that they
really accept nothing but the best which
I can see is being a blessing and a
curse at the same time I know Martha
Stewart is often teased about herself
that she's a perfectionist and she's
built an incredible Empire but I'm
wondering how do we let go of the
negative aspects maybe it's not possible
of perfectionism either in demanding
that of ourselves or of others I have an
exercise it's very simple and first of
all I will ask a class how many people
feel they had an issue with
perfectionism and virtually every single
hand will go up so everybody has
suffered at the hands of their
perfectionism and then I say all right
numbers from one to ten and then I say
number one if I didn't have to do it
perfectly I'd and have them fill in the
blank number two if I didn't have to do
it perfectly I and you go all the way up
it's a trend with the queue you go all
the way up to ten and what I find is
there
you provoke people into confronting
their own perfectionism in this way and
believe you also wrote that if we are
the authors of our lives why not write
them more actively and I'm curious in
light of this current economic downturn
and even with this situation in Japan
you know if especially if one is a
sensitive person picking up on on sort
of the collective mindset right now
where things just look pretty bleak how
do we how do we actively write that that
we can propel ourselves and keep our
mindset right this is where I think I
have two tools that I use together you
know first of all you have your morning
pages and they help you to make your own
personal life much more positive because
you will write something in your say oh
my god I have a choice where before you
felt you were a victim with morning
pages you start to see many Choice
points and so that's one thing I do
another thing I do is after people have
been working morning pages for about a
month I say all right now I want you to
do a week of reading deprivation and
people are horrified with me because
we're all addicted to reading and I say
make it even broader make it media
deprivation and for one week do not go
on your internet do not read your
newspapers do not listen to talk radio
know
I want you to just listen to yourself
for a weekend and people are just aghast
at this assignment and they get furious
with me but if they do it they come back
and they say I I found out so many
fascinating things that I believed that
I didn't know I believed I find so many
ideas to start that I didn't know I had
ideas to start in other words when you
do media deprivation you sort of cast
people back onto their own resources and
we find that they're very rich now
yeah really really horrified um I just
came back from Austin for South by
Southwest and boy you would have heard
crickets if you said that to that crowd
because that's is there something that's
maybe not so drastic like I personally
and I'm a culprit of cheating is I try
to not do that much I say that much
email on the weekends I'm real
especially as somebody who's a writer
and works independently you really can't
give it up cold turkey if you want to
keep you know paying the bills are there
things that people who just talking
about one week I would still hear
crickets from the people that I know
believe me but are there things that
people can do to have I guess focused
meditation a way to to get that
experience without juliek cameras not
gonna like me anymore
is there a way to to get that experience
without going the whole week are there
other ways to do that well I tell people
I teach adults
and some of its time we have to do some
media it's part of our job as I work and
I asked them to keep a log of every time
they did it and one of the things you
find is that suddenly people have a
compulsion to read TV Guide from
beginning to end you know that's
interesting and if you find yourself
acting out and just the act of keeping a
log makes you much more consciously
remember because we're what we're after
here is for you to fall in love with
yourself and if I tell people if you do
this tool you're going to have much more
autonomy and much more clarity then I
sometimes find that I do convince them
to do it and they report back that they
are thrilled with the result Giuliana
you know I'm sitting here and I'm
listening to you and your voice is so
soft and it's so soothing and you sound
so centered and and and part of me I you
know forgive me I can't help but ask do
you ever have a problem with with with
bullish behavior or people that sort of
like try to push you around or do you
ever have any trouble with that and if
you do how do you deal with that you
know with morning pages you you are
correcting the direction that you need
to move in different people have
different results from them if you're
somebody who always mouths off if you do
morning pages you start to keep your own
counsel if you are somebody who never
speaks up then when you do morning pages
you start to speaking up
and I think that morning pages give you
a platform to stand on and so when
somebody tries to bully you you may find
yourself saying I love it when you do
that another thing you've said which
kind of ties into this is keep the drama
on the page and I really like that
because for David and I will be trying
to get the the radio show together and
something will inevitably happen right
before we're about to leave the house or
or we have some very big project and and
the car breaks down the the sink
overflows and you talk about how I think
you were a single mother at the time and
you were writing and that statement keep
the drama on the page was really sort of
a key first to serenity for you and you
were able to to really compartmentalize
what was going on can you expand on that
explained it pretty well I think
one of the things that happened to black
voters you know that we become addicted
to negative drama and we have people in
our lives that I call crazy makers
people who destroy our schedules abused
our time abused our money and they
staged dramas but not where they belong
and so I had to I had to learn how to
say to myself I'm not going to
participate in this particular drama I
have a couple of people who are still in
my life and will remain in my life
because they're related by blood that
are very dramatic
and so I always have to listen to them
with a few deep breath and is there
anything because it sounds like you know
even with your family I mean is there do
you have any power in that circumstance
is there anything you can do as are the
things that you've tried to do they will
call me up immediately oh I just met
so-and-so we used to do tools and now he
has an album no man's a prophet in his
own land
that's what grandmother used to say
mm-hmm and and how do you how do you how
do you put yourself in a place where you
don't allow that distinct
you know because I imagine that that
does have to affect you that you know
here you are you have this work that's
been read by by millions of people and
yet some of the people that you care for
when you love the most
haven't taken the time to share in that
what you do is you call up your
girlfriend you believe it they do yeah I
wanted to touch on something that you're
launching it's um it's called Julia
Cameron live is that right what we call
a webinar it's an online seminar and it
replicates the teaching that I did at
the very beginning and when I had six
people in my living room and I was
available to answer questions and to
talk about the techniques in the book
and maybe tell some stories from my own
life about it
and
Julia Cameron live you there's a long
essay it's going to be about two and a
half hours and people will be able to
tune in to week one or go to week three
we repeat week I I like the ideas that
it makes teaching available to people
all over the world maybe can't come to
Cal Poly or Omega and hear me teach for
a weekend and of course when you make
something like this you are hoping for
the best and I find myself watching it
and after I got over the initial horror
oh my god that's what I look like I
found myself saying oh she seems kind
and trustworthy that's not a bad thing
in a teacher yeah none of them and where
can we find out more about this Julia
Cameron live it said Julia Cameron
live.com okay and it should be launched
in a couple of weeks a couple of weeks
okay Julia Cameron live.com this is
something a lot of Julia Cameron fans
I'm imagine it's gonna be really excited
about I found I enjoyed making it
it's the same old story of how I dread
teaching and then I teach and I find I
love it I was worried when we were
making it that I wouldn't be able to be
articulate enough to to be helpful and
what I found was that I was quite
articulate it is very clean and as we
wrap up the show here I just wanted to
throw out a few key words that you
you had mentioned in the artists way and
they're sort of the thousand-pound
elephant in the room that a lot of
people don't necessarily discuss when it
comes to creativity and some of those
words that stuck out were
competitiveness fame jealousy and shame
and I'm just wondering if you could just
give us a few thoughts on each I think
society and we are taught to view our
competitively and so when you read a
tabloid and it talks about an artist it
usually is talking about how much money
they've made so if you you are going to
talk about a screenwriter
you don't go to screenwriter a Comley at
the at the computer you know every day
for a week gently building up pages you
said you go to Joe Lester how him and
his million dollar sale and then people
tend to say oh if I'm not selling as
much as Esterhaus is selling I'm a
failure instead of saying hey I've got
33 pages of my script done I'm a success
so another thing I want to talk about is
shame which is very often when you make
a piece of art you have a whiplash
because you're sort of telling family
secrets you same look at it this way and
that means you're sort of stepping into
the into the clearing where critics can
take a potshot at you I saw a movie I
want to mention I don't know if you've
seen a movie called Barney's Version
if you did not get good reviews it is a
terrific movie and if you if you judge
it by its reviews you would think oh I
don't think I want to see that but if
you if you go to see it you come away
with such respect for the screenwriters
skill it's just it's just an incredible
film and then lastly Fame and jealousy I
know what jealousy you had talked about
poisonous playmates which I thought was
a fascinating idea that they're really
blocked creatives that are in your life
and that if you were to change and
blossom creatively then that would force
them as well and that might be to say
right yes lastly Julia you know there's
so many people that we know that that
have a hard time you know making time
for writing or anything creative you
know and and you know they they feel
like it's gonna take a year you know
they pick they have to black out a year
of their time to say okay I'm gonna go
out I'm gonna to go out and write the
next great American novel and I think
there's something that even some of your
students have have brought up to you
where they say they don't have time to
write and you've come back and you've
suggested about grabbing tiny segments
of time you know whether it be a coffee
break the dentist's office you know
waiting for a bus you know waiting for
the bus or the train you know can you
share any of your experiences in this
regard I think you know a book I wrote
called the sound of paper when I was
living in Taos there were fires and it
was very dangerous and I would drive out
every day to sort of see where the smoke
was and I started dictating the book to
my collaborator Emma lively and she
would sit in the car and take dictation
and I would dictate the essays in the
book and it was always a double use of
time
you know I was driving to Santa Fe on an
errand and PS we got an essay done and
now you have a digital recorder you
could just take with you when you're
driving in right as you go there that's
one thing about technology is it's made
excuses most of them I think go away
I have a question that I like to ask
people that I interview which is what do
you know now that you wish you knew at
the beginning of your career I have a
critic and I think all of us have an
inner critic and I called my critic
Nigel Nigel never thinks anything I do
is good enough and I have learned to
show when Nigel shares with me about how
terrible my writing is I have learned to
take that right into a believing here
and have the believing me reread it and
give me feedback which combats Nigel
however when I was a young writer I
didn't know that Nigel was a negative
voice and not the voice of experience so
I have novels and screenplays that have
just going to live in drawers and I wish
I had known about Nigel scalability when
I was a young writer I wish I had
trusted myself more I love that I
especially love that you named your
inner critic and I would recommend I'm
gonna do it I think I'm gonna name my
inner critic because I think that also
gives an extra quality to the voice in
your head and it's easier to combat it
oh and love that thank you you can do
that Nigel yeah okay now I'm wondering
which of the listeners is naming their
critic Simon Cowell thank you we've been
speaking with award-winning writer Julia
Cameron for more on Julia Cameron please
visit the artists Wacom the artists way
at work calm and Julia Cameron live calm
very shortly and for more on Deborah
eckerline please visit write on online
calm on Twitter at Wright on online
right on track la calm and right on
online on Facebook thank you both Julia
and Deborah for joining us on this
special edition of don't courage means
very much thank you thank you thank you
both yeah thank you both and and
certainly Julia Cameron fans you want to
stay tuned for Julia Cameron live which
is gonna we're gonna be seeing that
online and in about the next month or so
so what we're very excited for that we
will be back with a new episode of film
Kurds this Sunday at noon in our regular
time spot where we're gonna be speaking
with writer director of the film the
cosmonaut Nicolas Alcala you can find
out more about Nicolas by visiting
cosmonaut org also many thanks to our
guy Ronan Rosner who's actually here in
studio you know it's outside the studio
I'm here on a Wednesday here at Elliot
talk radio and bronan has is the one
that has built film curse comm and he
runs the board for the studio thank you
so much running and next Sunday we will
see you